[Aplausos]
eu conto histórias de vidas barradas por
uma ideia que se impôs pela força essa
idéia virou milhares de toneladas de aço
concreto e cimento no xingu um dos
grandes rios da maior floresta tropical
do mundo
o nome que deram essa ideia é belo monte
porque a violência também no ato de
nomear as coisas há quase um gozo belo
monte uma hidrelétrica que só produz
energia uma parte do ano porque na outra
parte do ano água do xingu encolhe ceca
esconde-se belo monte uma construção de
ruínas
o brasil é um grande construtor de
o brasil constrói o ina sim dimensões
continentais
dias atrás me perguntaram o que o rio
faria se pudesse falar macio fala a
gente não entende a habitar a pele do
rio para escutá lo mas mesmo humano que
o apito é apenas um micróbio às vezes
uma micose uma pequena vivendo nos poros
do rio
andamos sobre a cara e do rio mas não
habitamos de fato porque não alcançamos
a linguagem do rio
para nós da ruído que não se distingue
então o irmão explodido por dinamite eo
longe que dói e tudo silencia o rio não
está morto
apenas uma parte dele está muito ferida
mas soa como morte porque deixamos de
ouvir até mesmo ruído
o silêncio do xingu é um barulho
terrível
[Música]
ele nos deixa em suspense em suspensa
o silêncio do xingu é uma imensa de algo
um à beira de nesse ponto que estamos na
véspera o xingu hoje é uma véspera
os indígenas sabe os ribeirinhos sabe os
brancos não sabe eu conto histórias de
vidas barradas porque não entendo rio
minhas histórias mas sim dessa
impossibilidade de alcançar a linguagem
do xingu há mais de dez anos eu deito
meu corpo na língua desse rio esfrega
minha perna dele
retornei ao com as minhas unhas e sei
que o xingu é mulher mas não a linguagem
para mim então eu escuto as pessoas que
mais perto chegar aonde habitar o rio
escudos humanos
aqueles que compartilham as mesmas
cordas vocais que eu
o primeiro é mostrar que as palavras
podem ter as mesmas consoante as mesmas
lugares e mesmo assim não serem as
mesmas
foi um homem o chamado otávio das chagas
esse nome eu saberia em seguida era a
profecia otávio das chagas nasceu na
ilha de serra uma das milhares de ilhas
do xingu e seu corpo foi determinado por
essa experiência de viver sobre a terra
entre águas
otávio se fez pequeno para amenizar na
floresta e não pesar sobre a barriga do
rio ao deslizar sua canoa quando o time
voltava pra terra ele sabia que o rio
tinha menos peixes para fazer cócegas em
seu corpo de água e agradecida
eu já conhecia o homem arrancado por
belo monte
não sei se vocês já viram um homem
arrancado
é terrível horrorosa não está na sua
imagem mas a sensação que ele provoca o
curto está inteiro lá mas de faltam
partes
vou contar como eu sou disso o time já
estava com sua família na periferia de
altamira numa casa alugada era o ano de
2014 ele aos mais de 60 anos descobrir a
sua primeira fome belo monte o havia
tornado um pescador sem rio
tem peixe o tanque falava mas ele não
tinha palavras estava ali por que
assinar um papel que não era capaz de
ler as manchas no papel essas que ele
não pode decifrar e roubaram tudo
ele desapareceu no corredor apertado da
casa voltou de lá com uma pasta de
plástico
nela ele guarda os papéis que não
decifra mas que vão tirando nacos da sua
vida dentro daquela pasta estão as balas
perdidas e otávio das chagas
as balas achadas ele me mostra porque
acredita que eu possa ler os papéis mas
eu não sou boa
leitora de sentenças de morte
construídas com letras de advogado
eu pergunto da vida eu tava quero dizer
algo mas as palavras que chegam até mim
se desencontram elas alcançam meus
ouvidos mas nada dizem
são palavras esburacadas perdemo-nos dos
outros naquela casa do desespero ao
redor de nós altamir a rge
ela já é a cidade mais violenta do
brasil mas nós ainda não sabemos seu
filho francisco então faz um gesto
ele aponta para o seu copo próprio corpo
essa cicatriz foi quando machado caiu no
meu pé na ilha eu tinha dois anos
passa então a percorrer com meus ouvidos
e passa a escutar cicatrizes de otávio
das chagas
eu finalmente começa a entender são a
chave é notável que me contam porque as
chagas são tudo que lhe restaram seu
corpo é seu nome
o tazio das chagas é um refugiado do seu
próprio país é um refugiado em seu
próprio país
entendam o que eu demorei a entender
quando alguém é obrigado a deixar seu
país sua pátria sua matéria sua terra
por causa de fome guerras e epidemias
quando alguém é arrancado de seu país
pela geopolítica dos que detêm o poder e
os privilégios do planeta algo que fica
a um resto a uma materialidade que conta
que essa pessoa viveu mesmo que sejam
ruínas
mesmo que sejam seus mortos mas quando
alguém tem uma ilha afogada como
aconteceu com otávio das chagas a
memória virar água não a mata que de
materialidade a sua história tudo que
dizia que ele teve uma vida maria fez
nove cílios foi alegre triste foi quase
violentas e manssor tudo isso ele que
fez até os ossos do seu pai se perderam
então ele o filho apontou para o próprio
corpo desenhando um mapa nos ossos na
carne na pele conta a história de cada
cicatriz entende naquele momento que o
horror dos refugiados de belo monte o
word ser reduzido ao território do
próprio corpo
faltava só podia contar com as
cicatrizes das suas chagas para dizer
que existia era um homem à deriva na
certidão da cidade em colorado apenas em
si mesmo
qual é o nome dessa violência
vocês sabem entendi ali que se tratava
de palavras cicatrizes e desde então eu
escuto palavras cicatrizes também com os
meus dedos os refugiados de belo monte
não tem apenas corpo tem livros de
cabeceira
dias atrás eu fui contatado da saga de
sua família até a ilha de serra onde ele
nasceu
a ilha hoje está debaixo do paredão de
belo monte
sobrou apenas uma ponta e nós a pegamos
até lá depois de transpor a barreira com
nossos pés mas os seguranças expulsaram
da ilha porque são eles agora os guardas
diante de todas as portas e expulsaram
uma tábua das chagas em nome da
segurança do seu corpo
lá embaixo aos ossos do quadril o tav
a memória de uma vida toda literalmente
esmagada pelo paredão de belo monte
o rio agora tem banheiro desde que
construíram ruína sobre o corpo do xingu
a horas do dia em que ele se cresce para
controlar seus braços e pernas os braços
e pernas do vento lá também bunda e
seios
essa dança furiosa quase erótica
o banheiro não deixa ninguém passar
redemunho forte ex o rio expulsa todos
do seu corpo barrado
nessas horas o rio quer ter raiva
sozinho as palavras cicatrizes e otávio
das chagas me lançou no banheiro de
águas interiores e ela onde eu estou até
hoje
a escrita é essa que as manchas no papel
essa que está na pasta de otávio e de
tantos outros refugiados de belo monte é
essa que arranca tudo essa que a fascina
é uma das principais armas das elites em
várias épocas da história do brasil
a escrita é muito muito mas é também uma
arma para subjugar o primeiro a avisar
todos os outros que marcam a vida pela
oralidade pelo corpo do rio das árvores
das pedras de mapas feitos de outra
matéria
essa não é uma frase tentando ser
poética
estas não são muitas frases em busca de
efeito apenas é apenação eu conheço os
mortos desta escrita eu via o seu sangue
eu senti o cheiro de seus cadáveres eu
ouvi os gritos daqueles que os amável
eu estava o seu enterro a escrita no
brasil é essa que escreve para deixar de
fora é também dos poderes do direito da
medicina que isto para os ouvidos para
manter os muros como então meu que fiz
da escrita meu ser e não está no mundo
usa esse instrumento violento para
denunciar a violência
ao fazê-lo não estou também legitimando
a supremacia de uma narrativa sobre a
outra e assim perpetrando um ato jogo
sinto nem sei organizada
aprendi em 30 anos reportagem que só
podemos andar pelo mundo carregando
nossas contradições otávio das chagas me
ensinou que devemos seguir com o meu
gesto de escrever mas sem negar a
violência desse gesto escrever fazer
marca também no meu corpo
há também nem palavras cicatrizes
também eu me torna um livro de cabeceira
e nessa posição testemunha eu tava das
chagas para inclinar por três casas
diferentes
e nenhuma delas é a sua casa
os homens da empresa decretava isto não
é uma casa na sua casa no rio pra eles o
conceito de casa do leblon da vila
madalena do moinhos de vento
para otávio das chagas casa o telhado de
babaçu e também o ar que entra pela
porta jamais fechada são as fruteiras da
floresta os peixes no rio é a roça ea
liberdade não ir pra roça é curtia a
placa no mato
o canto dos macacos guariba na madrugada
em casa são também os vizinhos e as
brincadeiras no pôr do sol é o futebol
dos meninos e das meninas é onde se
amarra a rede pra quem chegar mas essa
casa não estava inscrita nos papéis dos
homens da empresa
quem diz o que é uma casa quem diz quem
é aquele que é o tabu das sagas e sua
família foram do aluguel para o
recenseamento do recenseamento uma casa
doada nunca chegaram em casa não
chegaram enquanto não houver rio
ribeirinhos como ele chama a cidade de
rua
vou pra rua vem da rua otávio das chagas
está na rua o que significa que está
fora hoje ele está um habitante do fora
é também por estar fora dentro de otávio
das chagas e tantos são refugiados em
seu próprio país mas e ribeirinho
beradeiro é ser um habitante do entre
mundo
os antepassados do que se chama
beradeiros os ribeirinhos no brasil
foram carregados do nordeste do país no
fim do século 19 para cortar seringa
para fazer borracha na floresta
amazônica fugiam da seca de séculos de
jogo nas mãos anuladas dos coronéis na
selva foram submetidos às relações de
trabalho muito semelhantes às da
escravidão mataram indígenas e foram
mortos por indígenas
muitos fizeram famílias com mulheres
indígenas às vezes pelo seqüestro e pelo
estupro na segunda guerra o exército de
nordestinos pobres foram levados até
floresta para todos e borracha
em cada uma das vezes sempre com
interesse comercial despencou foram
abandonados na mata pelos patrões e ali
criaram um modo de viver de quê da
margem não uma experiência de exclusão
uma de liberdade navegar entre os mundos
tendo como fronteira o corpo do rio
tornou-se uma estratégia de
sobrevivência
os verdadeiros pesca e carros são
quebram castanha tiram a sair plantão
roça fazem faria às vezes criam galinhas
podem cortar seringa se o preço estiver
bom que garimpa um pouco quando aparece
uma fofoca de ouro no passado cansado
muito a onça crb estar aqui e ali é ser
isso e também aquilo ribeirinho
habitantes das beiras
essa é múltiplo e é ser entre eles que
eram pobres não seria abandonar os
patrões como carne barata e já
exaustivamente usada apropriaram-se do
próprio corpo
é comum ouvir os descendentes dos
primeiros blogueiros proclamarem com
orgulho
nunca ninguém mandou em mim ou nunca
tive um emprego a liberdade está em se
mover pelo rio pelas lidas pelos desejos
mas como se mover no rio agora barrado
quando a pressão pela terra aumentou na
amazônia os brasileiros avançaram para
perto das margens com seus pistoleiros
muitos baladeiros ocuparam as
domingo era o último reduto de
resistência não de uma vida mais uma
saga da certidão do semiárido nordestino
aos excessos do rio
então belo monte o fogo às ilhas e os
verdadeiros foram reconvertidas em
pobres agora urbanos
perguntei a alguns deles o que é ser
pobre
ser pobre é não tem escolha o que comer
de onde ir de onde vir do que fazer ou
não fazer
ser pobre é não ter escolha sobre o
desejo
perguntei a eles o que é ser rico
ser rico é não precisar de dinheiro
é preciso entender também isso os
verdadeiros não são apenas vítimas de
uma idéia de desenvolvimento que mata
esse olhar redutor da enormidade do que
são os ribeirinhos do xingu de outros
rios amazônicos carrega no corpo uma
insurreição sua encarnação de um levante
enquanto que se chama de brasil vivia
isso e aquilo eles fizeram uma revolução
na margem e à margem do estado tornaram
se uma experiência totalmente singular
que subverte o poder a subverter o
movimento da vida que questionava todas
as escrituras tornaram-se uma
experiência única não como entes da
floresta mas como entre eles então o
estado chegou não para garantir direitos
mas para construir ruínas e as ilhas
quilombos viraram água
as árvores mortas estendem seus braços
acusadores em direção ao céu ea pele do
rio apodrece a água agora cheiro a
cadáver mas não é o rio que morre
somos nós aqueles que sempre temeram a
catástrofe na larga noite do mundo e
agora se tornaram a catástrofe
eu quero contar pra vocês que eu escuto
as vidas barradas do xingu
e fracasso em convertê las em palavras
fracassar é uma condição de quem escreve
a vida sempre escapa vida transborda a
vida é maior a vida flui na palavra mas
não aceita ser barrada por ela quem me
ensinou que escrever um ato do corpo no
corpo foi o xingu o que eu tenho para
oferecer sou eu mesma esse corpo feito
de palavras cicatrizes
esse corpo tragicamente insuficiente
mais presente
hélio alves da silva um pescador que viu
o poeta quando foi apertada do rio me
disse que a gente perde todas as lutas
se contar apenas comum mas podemos
romper as barragens se nos torná los
mais um e mais um e mais um muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]